♪ ♪
>> Tucker: HE IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE AGAINST
THE UNELECTED INCUMBENT LAST
NIGHT A MAN CALLED DAVID
ATTEMPTED TO STAFF HIM DURING A
CAMPAIGN EVENT AND CHARGE THE
STAGE WITH THE BLADE DURING THE
ATTACK.
>> THERE'S ONLY ONE OPTION.
YOU'RE DONE, YOU'RE DONE, YOU'RE
DONE.
>> Tucker: SO HOW DID HE KNOW
WHERE HE WAS DAYS BEFORE THE
ATTACK KATHY ONCE AGAIN HIS
GOVERNOR HAS NOT BEEN ELECTED
GOVERNOR SENT OUT AN EMAIL
LISTING THE UPCOMING CAMPAIGN
APPEARANCES AND TONER SUPPORTERS
THAT HE IS AN EXTREMIST IS AN
EXTREMIST THEY'RE IN TROUBLE SHE
IS DANGEROUS FOR NEW YORK NOT
JUST WRONG BUT DANGEROUS WHAT A
NUTCASE SHE IS FACILITY WITH THE
VACCINATED NECKLACE.
AFTER THE ATTACK THEY PREDICTED
THAT THE MAN TRY TO STAB HIM GET
OUT AND SHOW QUICKLY THANKS TO
THE BAIL LAWS THAT IS OF COURSE
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED THE
ATTACKER WAS RELEASED FROM JAIL
WITH NO BAIL OF ANY KIND YOU
JUST SAW IS A MAN WHO DID IT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AMERICAN
VETERANS HE JOINED I THINK SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON I BLESS YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DID YOU DIDN'T
HESITATE AT ALL YOU SEEM TO HAVE
KEYED IN ON THIS GUY RIGHT AWAY
HOW?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON
TUCKER SO I WAS THE MASTER OF
CEREMONY THE RALLY LAST NIGHT
I'M ALSO RUNNING FOR STATE
ASSEMBLY IN THAT AREA AND REPORT
ABOUT 5 MINUTES BEFORE THE
INCIDENT I NOTICE A SHOWMAN
WALKING INTO THE RALLY KIND OF
STAGGERING HE DIDN'T SEEM RIGHT
IS REALLY HIGH-ENERGY LARGE
CROWD JUST DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE
THE VIBE TOOK NOTICE OF THAT
CENTER JUST OFFSTAGE SIAM WALK
OFF TO THE SIDE OF THE STAGE FOR
THE PEOPLE STOOD THERE THERE
WATCHING I CONTINUE TO WATCH A
LITTLE BIT TO THE CONSUMMATE AS
WELL.
I JUMPED UP ONTO THE STAGE I
COULDN'T GET TO WHERE HE WAS AT
THAT TIME SO I RAN AROUND BEHIND
THE STAGE CAME UPON THE CONGRESS
DID KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THIS GUY'S
INTENTIONS WERE I WATCHED HIM
AND HE WALKED DIRECTLY UP TO THE
CONGRESSMAN AS YOU VIEWERS JUST
SAW.
TOLD HIM THAT YOU'RE DONE AND HE
PULLED A WEAPON THAT WAS
ATTACHED TO HIS HANDS SWUNG AT
CONGRESSMAN'S FACE OR HIS THROAT
AREA THEY ARE ABLE TO BLOCK THAT
STRIKE HER ATTEMPTED STRIKE AT
THE WRIST AS HE PULLED THE
RESPECT TO TRANSFERRING AGAIN I
GRABBED HER FROM BEHIND WAS ABLE
TO BEAR HUG HIM AND SENT HIM
DOWN TO THE GROUND WILL BE ABLE
TO EVENTUALLY GET HIS WEAPON
AWAY FROM HIM UNTIL
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAME.
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU HAVE
SUCH HIGH SITUATIONAL AWARENESS?
>> I WAS A MARINE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS ACTIVE DUTY FOR IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN IS WHEN THE
INSTINCTS KICKED IN AS WELL WAS
REALLY BLESSED TO BE AROUND SOME
REALLY FAST REACTING PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I'M GLAD YOU WERE
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON LUCK GETTING